[Music]
everywhere
i go lately people tell me that i need
to interview
eric july it doesn't matter what state
i'm in it doesn't matter what we're
talking about
i was at tim poole's place uh not not so
long ago he said you gotta talk
to eric july i said okay i gotta learn
about this guy so i look up eric july
also known as young ripa 59
i had already reserved young ripa 58
which is why he had to go to 59.
he's got some really really terrific
commentary in particular
on the entertainment media and
specifically about comic books but this
guy is a man of many many talents
you also may have seen him in the thomas
soul documentary
which is really terrific thomas soul
common sense in a senseless world
so we're going to try to make sense of
this senseless world eric thank you for
coming on
i appreciate you having me michael thank
you so much so i need you to
educate me about a topic on which i am
entirely
ignorant and this is the topic of comic
books i want i won't say that i'm
entirely ignorant here is what i know
i only know what i read in the news that
all of a sudden comic books which i
thought
it's just a fun thing that people you
know either people with a very specific
interest or you know people growing up
they read them they keep hiring
radical leftists to write them in
particular there's that guy tom nehesi
coates who i think
may be the single most overrated writer
in america today
i'm the guy who wrote a book without any
words and i think that this guy is way
way over
overrated so tell me i mean is this just
some strange coincidence i mean what
what is going on behind the scenes in
the comic books
yeah it's not a coincidence at all it
seems like within the last uh
decade um i would say more so in the
middle of the of the 2010s you started
to see this big time like cultural shift
in in terms of who were writing these
books
now often you'd get people that were
already part of like the comic book
culture like you mentioned kind of it is
niche it takes a certain kind of person
to even
write and be knowledgeable on these on
these characters definitely the
of the marvels and the dc's and
mainstream comics
and at some point like the 2010s they
shifted and rather
seemed to focus on hiring people that
were more so
fitting a particular social or political
view
and this is why you've got guys like
taina hissy coast
writing uh unfortunately black panther
one of my favorite
uh uh characters and he had no business
being anything near
that project that intergalactic wakanda
or whatever weird thing
he called himself doing to me it's the
worst run of black panther that we've
ever got
but you can check the receipts on that
tana he said coach there's no
evidence even that he was even like into
comic books
uh prior to being hired as a writer for
for marvel comics so those are the types
of hires that that we're getting guys
like chinese because
it's a literal award with the harriet
beecher store war for social justice i'm
pretty sure that has something to do
with why he fit that position
and they seem to try to cater to people
and bringing people on to write their
projects
writing for people that don't read books
right he does have a specific
demographic an already established
demographic
and their sales are really really
hurting and you're seeing that because
of that because they
have focused on social uh views and
political views
as opposed to actually entertaining uh
their their audience and this is
why right now for example in america in
the west for the first time i believe
ever the nbd book scans read that
the japanese comics the mangas had the
top 20
were all mangas in america the top 20
sales were all manga
because that's where people are going to
get their more like kind of comic book
hero based uh sort of material they have
just completely dumped a marvel and they
should be
embarrassed but it doesn't seem like
they are because they keep doubling down
well this is
one of the problems that i think
conservatives are grappling with right
now
so you look at the numbers you look at
book scan americans are not buying the
american comics anymore they're buying
the japanese comics
so what i think a lot of conservatives
what we've told ourselves for the past
few decades of insane leftist aggression
on the culture wars is we'll say look
eventually the almighty dollar is going
to win out they're going to put out
really bad stories and eventually
because they're not going to have any
sales they're going to be forced
to go back to producing entertaining
normal content
and i keep waiting and i keep waiting
for it from the movies
and i don't read comic books but i would
be waiting for it from the comic books
and it just doesn't happen so is it are
they just willing to take the financial
loss
to push the woke ideology i think that's
exactly
what it is and i think look they they
did cater to a really flaky audience i
think that stuff kind of works a little
more for the
like the i guess the movies uh film tv
shows
way more than it works for something
like the comic books
but they are more i guess maybe it's
twitter maybe it's the instagrams of the
world and they're more like
signaling to that kind of weird bizarre
audience which does not
even represent a significant portion of
the population at least not of actual
customers
um and yeah they just when you think
they can't get worse
you see again and i was believe that was
april top 20 you think these comic pros
would be looking at that like okay we
got a pivot
we have to pivot we cannot just keep
putting out this dog crap and then
i was just reading the other day uh they
put
for one odd reason they made elektra
daredevil now and their devil was no
longer a guy
uh electra's daredevil and they she's
being lectured by some like trans person
about
other bullcrap that has no it's so out
of character for not only a lecture but
just
that's what they're doing is pride month
they're trying to signal and do all of
that stuff
so yeah they keep doubling down so i do
think at some point the pendulum is
going to swing
but what will it take it's hard to say
but things like dc and this was
what a lot of com comic book fans feared
not myself necessarily people that are
way smarter than me
they feared once it went mainstream
mainstream and used that in quotes and i
guess
they got tied to these mega corporate
entities they could take that loss
a lot more than what they could back
back in the past so they're willing to
take it
probably guys at the top aren't even
seeing and we know they're not making
money but you know how disney works
disney can
can uh do 10 projects one of them can
succeed and they'll be it'll fund the
rest of
everything it is that they that they do
so they can take the hit
because they're not necessarily
answering directly to the customers
uh like other like more smaller entities
have to so that's the one benefit that
they have
they can continue to take those loss
because they're able to make up for the
losses elsewhere but we'll it'll be
interesting to see
there's been plenty of rumors and that
maybe uh you know as att i believe owns
dc now they're talking about selling
that
stuff off and we'll see how long disney
keeps ahold of it because the only thing
that they can make money off of it is
maybe the movies and even those are
starting to take
take uh starting to take a down turn and
the merchandise but that's about it as
far as the books
don't be surprised if at some point even
marvel or or
just excuse me disney or atsc say you
know we're not even going to put these
out we may do reprints or something like
that but you guys aren't making any
money but
it doesn't sound like they're in the
business of actually making money this
is a problem throughout the corporate
media it's true in the news media it's
true in the movies it's
you know these these entities are very
often owned by much
larger corporate entities who don't
really care you know if if the woksters
in the executive suites
want to push a message they just don't
really care about the relatively small
amount of money they're going to lose
and that
i do think it's been a big problem that
conservatives
basically have thought that the most
important issue to people
they wake up in a cold sweat in the
middle of the night
thinking about some marginal tax cut and
occupational licensing reform
i like those things i'm not against them
i'm just saying other
other impulses move men's hearts and
minds
now so i'm totally on board for
fighting in the culture taking back the
culture using our political power to do
it
the thing i can't get that into is the
comic books i just just as a personal
mat it's just
a preference thing do i need to pay
attention
is the fact that these comic book
characters are going totally woke
is that actually going to have tangible
effects
on our society or is that one area that
i can just ignore
it's a niche interest and i'll focus
elsewhere
that's a great great question i think
when you look at for example what
like for example hollywood in the last
10 years i think you you can't really
ignore it because you look at the marvel
cinematic universe
uh for example they were just pumping
out billion dollar films like it was
going out of style
um and that is that that's that's
influential
and uh you're right in terms of
conservatives libertarians uh
this is something i've been trying to
shake their shoulders on not necessarily
with the comic books but also with the
other
things that i do whether it be with the
music stuff and everything else i'm
saying
yeah we have the arguments on our side
but is that good enough
i don't think so and this is what a lot
of the left give i have to give them
credit they played the long game and
there was nothing off limits for them
nothing it would i say if it was the
more more influential that it was they
were like all right
let's get a hold of it and they played
the long game and i think what you're
seeing now is the
the effects especially over the last
last year when you can't turn off i
can't even turn on a video game
without seeing black lives matter uh on
freaking soccer game or something like
like fifa it's nonsense like i don't
play video
that's i'm supposed to get away with
that but i think the left had benefited
from both libertarians and conservatives
thinking that those are trivial things
like like we don't
people don't care about that type of
thing but it's a very influential thing
especially when it comes to like younger
generations that stuff that they have
their nose in so often that's something
that they're intrigued by
and and i'm like you in a sense that
there are other subject matters that i
simply do not
care about but i can't deny if they are
important and if they are influential
definitely if someone is able to be more
like they can communicate in whatever
subculture it is that they are in and i
think that's if there's gonna ever be a
tied shift
towards liberty people that actually
value liberty and private property
rights
that's where it's going to happen it's
not necessarily i believe
politics i believe that's more so on the
downstream you change this and people's
minds and hearts starts to change
and then maybe that manifests itself in
other ways maybe it is in a political
sphere maybe it's somewhere
else but the left they have everything
because for a very long time
both libertarians and conservatives
neglected a lot of that and we just
simply didn't think it was as important
as what it actually was and this is why
so many of these like these younger
folks
they they got them in i mean it doesn't
matter what it is that they pump out
they walk right hand in hand with them
and uh yeah they listen to them that's
right you
you may not care about the culture but
the culture cares about you and i
you know people do this a lot with the
pronoun issue we'll say should i call
bruce jenner he
or she and we everyone gets into big
debates about this and
some of the more squishy conservatives
they'll often say
who cares right it's the same thing on
the comic books it's the same thing in
all these aspects of the culture
oh who cares uh the left cares
the left seems to care quite a lot which
is why they're losing a lot of money
pushing these messages
they're hiring these radicals like ton
easy codes they're hot
they're really focused on it because
they know that the culture can carry
whole premises through to it but i
wonder i wonder if part of it is
conservatives have just and libertarians
have just ignored it and they just
don't really care that much but also
what would we do with the power
if we actually knew to wield it but by
that i mean the left has a very specific
vision
of society america is evil racist sexist
whatever you know it's all sort of
terrible stuff
we got to tear it down and pull down
statues in washington okay
what is the conservative response what
is our substantive view of things
do we have one or is it just that we
can't really agree on anything so the
only thing we do when we have power is
temporarily cut taxes a little bit yeah
see that
that's always the the question that i
think is very difficult for people that
again no matter what it is you call
yourself it's just if you value liberty
like what's next obviously you brought
it i mean i believe that stems from
obviously the marxism it is that they
that they advocate where it's just
anything that exists uh they want to
make sure they tear it down and build it
up
in a way or build a backup in a way that
they they envision it this sort of
anti-anti-property rights uh
more radical egalit yeah i use that term
loosely egalitarian
sort of approach where we're all like
equal robots when we know that's
absolutely not the case but let them
tell it that's what they believe
i think this is why like i was focused
so much on like decentralization so much
because if anything
if there's anything else to focus on
because you're right
i do believe that there's a lot of
people that value liberty that are on
different sides of just
different like subject matters they they
they differ so much and it's like okay i
just want to be left alone
right the left doesn't want to leave you
alone and this is why they they they get
the power and they're like look
we we are we're here to destroy and
they're pretty blatant and pretty honest
about it
we just want to be left alone and we
want other people to just be able to
go about their life without being able
to either be aggressed upon and
obviously them not
having the right to use aggression upon
upon peaceful people
and this is why that has to stay at the
top if you are
in any sort of advocacy position or
really in any position
of influence it has to stay at the top
and you have to be loud and
unfortunately a lot of conservatives
seem to lose sight of that
even the ones that you know focus a lot
on okay i just want to own the libs and
stuff like that i mean i get it
but is that actually going to work us
towards a more freer
a more prosperous society right and this
is why decentralization is such a focus
of mine because it's like
we're not going to agree on how this
power needs to be willed
so at minimum if we can try to like get
i don't know get rid of it so when we
don't have nancy pelosi and these other
quacks out of the out there
in washington i've made this argument on
the blaze every day that i'm there
i'm less about arguing with nancy pelosi
about who should be in her position i
want to pull the rock from up under her
so that she doesn't have
any sort of of influence so they can't
make the decisions that it is that
more so impacts our life this is why we
get so uh up in
armed so maybe we have to change that
part of the power structure
as opposed to just wielding it and just
sorry focusing on
yeah we may get a tax cut he'll make it
a tax cut there but it has it has to
come with
mountains of like corporate corporate
welfare and all sorts of things that
we're funding they compromise definitely
we see this with a lot of even the
conservatives they'll compromise on
or the republicans compromise on certain
things okay we'll give you this this and
that
portfield bill two trillion dollars
let's devalue your money in the first
place
and we don't really work towards liberty
and that's what has to be kept in mind i
wish i would
i would love to hear or see rather
republicans
actually keeping that at the forefront
of what their advocacy actually is the
term that i like to use is that they
tend to campaign
like libertarians and then govern like
democrats
i would love to change that well there's
this strange
paradigm i don't know if it's really a
paradox but it but it is a
strange circumstance that at least since
reagan
at least since republicans have really
embraced as you say the kind of
libertarian language on the campaign
trail
they actually have put put forward some
policies in that
direction you know they focused a lot on
economic deregulation
okay and the the democrats i find since
around the same time maybe a little
earlier
have focused a lot on social
deregulation you know you can sleep with
whoever you want you can kill a baby in
the womb you can kind of do whatever you
want
and so you know in a weird way they've
both kind of deregulated
and yet as you rightly point out we seem
to
be in the most centralized powerful
government you know maybe in the history
of the world
so how does that happen i mean how has a
process that i don't think is just
totally disingenuous i think they
actually have
deregulated in certain pretty noticeable
ways but how has that deregulation then
led to
a more powerful centralized government i
can't make sense of it
right and it is i think it's because
they they're not focusing on the
i guess the power more so in itself it's
more so okay
i'll take this slight victory here um
there's it's more topic to topic and i'm
not
i'm not against like single issues or
focusing on people have their expertise
and stuff that they
they actually value and i think that's a
valuable thing that people focus on
whatever it is that
they find as the strengths of something
that it is that they care about
but what happens is they lose sight of
what the
actual like core principle is and that's
liberty
for example this is why i don't take
leftist serious when they complain about
let's say things like police brutality
that is not anything to take serious
from them
because they have no problem with the
cops whooping up on you any event
in the event that it's for something
that they want to to advocate for
which is why they're like non-existent
in the event or they'll be like
contradict themselves like we saw with
the whole january 6
uh thing they're doing vigils and all of
this for that lie of uh
right brian sicknick being beat over the
head with a fire extinguisher which of
course turned out to not even be true
but that's the type of stuff that they
do because for them it's it's less
it's not necessarily about the
deregulation it's more about what can we
do
to destabilize uh let's say what exists
right now
so we can actually capture that power
so this is why even though they claim to
be okay like even with the drugs they
like to think that they're the party
against the war on drugs which is
bullcrap
but they like to think that but it seems
to always lead
like to what you said more
centralization that's because liberty
isn't really on their focus it's more
single issue single issue what do i have
to do or what do i have to advocate
to become prominent and to get the power
and when you don't focus on the private
property right element of what it is
that we're
we're discussing then yeah you're gonna
lose sight of that and this is what we
have right now
big bloated centralized uh mess and
unfortunately it's ruining a lot of
people's lives well and you've totally
hit the nail on the head on this power
struggle i notice even
on the the issues where they talk about
liberty you'll notice
they never really mean liberty in the
way that you know a conservative person
would talk about it
they mean they mean licentiousness the
only they're not really interested in
the liberty to
tamp down your appetites and govern
yourself and exert political control
they only talk about liberty and like
shooting up
dope or something liberty is the kind of
degrade us and take us out of our heads
and so what degeneracy than anything
that's right yeah i mean these are
things by the way the founding fathers
explicitly said they said do not
abuse liberty to licentiousness it's a
bad idea you're going to lose your
self-government
if you do that so they do this all the
time but then i wonder
do conservatives need and i wonder this
i i
you know this is sort of a thesis that
i've put out there i know it's very
controversial
but do conservatives need a substantive
vision
meaning what we've tried to do i think
with the best of intentions
is is nothing and what i mean by that is
you know you get power and you say
i'm not gonna regulate i'm not gonna do
this i'm not gonna
we're gonna let people make their own
decisions leave them alone and then the
left won't leave anybody alone and the
left won't let anybody be left alone and
it's just not going to happen so you
know
a republican wins and and we basically
freeze the culture and we say okay we've
got sort of a break for the next two or
four years
and then the democrats win and they push
the culture to the left
and then maybe a republican wins and we
freeze it again and so you know if you
if you follow that process
we're going to be over the cliff on the
left and not not too
far into the future so how do how do we
reverse it how do we how do we go in the
other direction
right and this is why you know i know
malice and other guys
use the whole well this is what they're
like progressives going to speed limit
is more so what it is that you're
that that you're saying and this is what
what frustrates me so much
probably the most about a lot of
republicans that are in the positions
of power because often they're never on
the offense
right always on defense they're always
on the defense and even when it comes to
something as
fundamental like which is where
libertarians conservatives we all agree
we value the uh like gun ownership gun
rights the second amendment
they only get on offense when they think
that a democrat is taking it to them so
we got for example i'm out where i'm out
in texas and
you know we got governor abbott who
calls himself trying to basically make
texas
a a a a sanctuary uh uh city in terms of
the second amendment what took you so
long
like why all of a sudden are you now
on the offense and we've seen it it's
more so when like i said they're more
about
owning the the libs it's more so taking
it to them
and being against them and this is what
i called about the election i said
don't be so frightened to really think
that they're just going to get this
power and do whatever it is that
they want they'll attempt to do but what
you're going to see is the more
offensive republican party
uh or at least the ones that you know
semi-value liberty you're going to see a
more offensive republican party because
now they can at least make the excuse
that well we're trying to stop them or
we'll start trying to take it take it to
them
uh in some way so what the what people
that if you desire any sort of political
power or whatever it is
you have to be on the absolute offense
but just sitting there
and thinking well i'm in this position
we'll be in on the defense uh
for as long as my term is isn't an
effective thing
and you've seen that leftists get in
power and they're like i'm implementing
whatever it is
that i can and maybe this conversation
maybe it won't happen right now but i at
least get the conversation started in
four or five years
uh from now something gets implemented
and you know we're moving
it's not moving towards liberty it's
moving to the absolute opposite way so
they have to get on the offense and stop
uh more so being reactionary and waiting
for them to do something the leftists do
something and then
uh people that are in power be poli
libertarians or conservatives or whoever
they're like okay now i'm gonna do
something
how about do something all the time you
know that you've
hit the nail on the head here especially
with this pun
offensive and i think of trump
who goes on the offense and he is
offensive
he says offensively but but it is
important i'm not saying people need to
be impolite i'm not saying they need to
be cruel or anything like that
but trump calls it like he sees it and
he doesn't
engage in these sort of abstract
ideological things from
a think tank somewhere and he crucially
doesn't accept the left's premises
he goes he launches his campaign what
does he do he comes down the escalator
and he says look we've got foreign
nationals pouring into our country with
crime and drugs and it's ruining
communities
and people hate this country now and i'm
not going to let you i'm going to hug
the american flag he literally would hug
it
he'd kiss the american flag he'd say
look i don't care about your kooky
theories
we're going to stand up we're going to
get better trade deals we're going to
bring manufacturing back
you think we can't i think we can looks
like we can and you know it's such a
he always had the democrats on the back
foot he always had them reacting
to whatever he tweeted that's why they
had to kick him off twitter is because
he was
setting the narrative and i guess this
actually brings us right back to our
first topic
the left with few exceptions maybe trump
is the one exception
the left sets the narrative right the
left
decides the terms of of what we can say
of how we behave
even what we think and we're all left
just living in their world
that's that's uh that means you put it
about as perfectly as it
as it could be and that's why i've said
about the trump phenomena
it's less about the policies with him
whether you feel like
you know obviously me not being a big
being a fan of him
or others i said that doesn't matter the
thing to focus on
with him that anybody of any that
is in a political sphere can take from
that is the fact that
he at least controlled the conversation
probably for the first time if we want
to be realistic
you mentioned since reagan maybe since
then that they actually
control the conversation so the leftists
were reacting based upon
everything it is that he did as opposed
to what they had been doing classically
and back to really what they're doing
right now
and that's being on the complete defense
so that's something that people can
learn from what i love for those
policies to be at i mean
top liberty more than everything of
course that's what it is
that we want and that's the perfect
storm or rather the perfect world we
have someone that
a hundred percent values uh liberty i'll
take 90. uh
90 of values liberty but is also on the
offense in
trying to bring about that in our world
and really
within our lifetime because this is
something that that we want so we have
to stop
reacting based upon what the what the
left is doing this is what i've been
saying
with for example people that value
liberty like say in the cultural space
the number i've thrown out there is 51
51
is all i ask of people to go out of
their way and search for people that are
in these subcultures because we're here
we're here
in these subcultures and use 50 percent
of your time
uh money uh the good stuff not the corny
stuff that yeah there's people that are
making alternatives that aren't really
good but think they should be supported
just because they create an alternative
no there are people that actually do
good stuff
and i think with 51 of people just going
out the way
looking instead of being reactionary go
out of your way and look for this
material that's out there
and then you'll start to see the
pendulum the pendulum swings because
right now really they're able to get
away with what it is because well
and everything it is that we do we
accept them as like the
norm that's why they have the
entertainment sector and we accept
it has to be star wars it has to be dc
it has to be marvel it has to be star
trek and they've ran all of those into
the ground
and they control them and we have to
unfortunately
we got to say look they got them they
have them maybe we should be looking to
uh certain alternatives to try to get
the pendulum to swing back that's great
i love your point that
we can't make corny stuff you know
there's so much corny stuff on the right
i can't wait man yeah it's you know
really
we're here you know at daley wire moved
to nashville basically to make movies
because there was
so much less regulation taxes were a lot
lower it really gave us the freedom
to make stuff and i think so many of us
just want the freedom
to make stuff and you know you've
reminded me in your discussion of
liberty
the left always redefines the words
right they always pervert the language
that's how they redefine the culture
and they nowhere is that truer than on
liberty they define liberty you know the
founding fathers had a
pretty decent definition of liberty and
people
john locke for that matter had a real it
was a lit
his liberty you know you had a lock you
had john milton sure
and burke i think expressed it the best
you know this kind of ordered liberty
that lets
everybody flourish and it's just a
really civilized great way to live
and the left has just totally perverted
that flipped it
on its head as they have so much of our
language if they have so much of our
culture
and so okay we've thoroughly depressed
everybody
is there any hope i mean in a really
nuts and bolts way
how do i walk into marvel or dc tomorrow
and i say hey i have no idea what your
product is
but i want to uh i want to write it now
i want to take it back
how do we reclaim these these
institutions that the left
has has taken from us i think there's
just two ways to attack this great
question
first and foremost there are a lot of
people who reach out to me definitely
because comic books are the main thing
that
that i cover i cannot tell you the
amounts of
of artists writers who have reached out
to me
a lot of the prints that you see ones on
my wall i won't even point to which one
it is
but a lot of the prints that i get are
directly from the artists
like i love that poster that is of this
what did you get that it was signed and
everything the artist sent it to me
the artist sent it to me and they're
like well this is more like an
undercover thing
because they don't want to end up like
gina carano and it's like well
i i agree with a lot of what you say
it's crazy this industry
but i can't see it i get that with music
my band backwards we go on tour
and we see drummers and whatever of
other bands man we love what it is that
you guys say
we can't say that uh-huh yeah you can
and until y'all do it
nothing changes now the other side is i
guess on the on the customer because we
got
people that valued liberty got too
comfortable and we
we neglected it and we were just like
okay if i like it i see it
i'm i'm not even going to be mindful of
who's creating it i don't care
and unfortunately they make money off of
off off of the people that value liberty
because of that and then they win awards
and then they get on the ward show and
tell you how much they hated you because
you didn't vote for the right person
so this is why i i'm not as though i
know i talk about the bad a lot
i'm not necessarily pessimistic because
just as quick as it got bad it can get
better
but what it does requires a conscious
effort for people to go out of their way
and seek this
this this information instead of just
relying upon what
the people that have already gained in
control what they put out there we
talked about twitter and
the trending topics all of those are
fake bought all of that stuff
it's not organic or anything like that
but they'll put it in your face and have
you thinking that it's legitimate so
what people have to do
is go out of their way that's why i said
51 i can't expect you to just
stop all together wouldn't that be nice
if people just said okay if if it's
owned by these crazy uh leftists i'm not
even going to support it that'd be
fantastic
but i i think that's a little
unrealistic this is why i just say just
slightly over half
of your money time and effort and
revenue investments
going towards people that are involved
in these these uh these subcultures
that it's not about them let's say being
a libertarian being a conservative or
something like that it's more of them i
don't know not hating you
yeah you know instead of instead of
supporting the ones
that do so just as quick as it did get
bad it can be
get better but it just requires the
customers to think differently and i
know because we have the
ideas on our on our side we'd love to be
in a perfect world where that didn't
matter
but they have already drew the line in
the sand and it is what it is they've
made it abundantly clear
that they will take your money and
investments and then tell you how much
you
suck so let's try to change that and go
seek out those people who
who are the actual creatives and the
people that are the creators that are
already let's say
maybe with those mega entities out
yourself out yourself and it's got to be
on the customers to go catch them
that's right that's that's the key it's
not enough to say hey eric
hey i i like what you said but i can't i
don't want to
you know no you know what you know what
is even better than getting invited to
the fun party or getting the promotion
at your
corporation you know what's even better
than that integrity having integrity is
good and having a good
thriving flourishing free country with
good a good way of life that that's
important too eric where can people find
you
you can find me of course uh youtube
young ripper five nine
um also eric d july if you wanna get
links to everything i know i do a
million things
at once so you can catch me of course
over there and we do four canon
uh sake let's say every day 12 p.m uh on
the channel you can catch that as well
and obviously doing news and wire
matters and everything over at blaze
it's been awesome by the way
uh michael and i appreciate you know you
you having me on like i said i already
we crossed paths a lot and i think it's
important that we do have these
conversations so they they know that
we're locked in oh pleasure is all mine
i'm so glad you could come on don't
forget you can find me
at young ripa 58 and then because that
one was already taken you can find
eric july young ripa59 eric talk to you
next time
all right man see you soon
you